كثيره هي السيناريوهات التي نسجت حول
مستقبل مجموعه فاجنر ومصير رئيس حتى قبل
الاعلان رسميا عن مصرعه في حادث تحطم
طائرته شمال موسكو الدور الذي ينتظر فاجنر
بعد مصر زعيمها رفقه كبار معاونيه وهل
طويت صفحتها كذراع عسكريه واقتصاديه
ريبوسكو وما مصير نفوذها في البلدان التي
كانت تنشط فيها خصوصا الافريقيه منها ما
مستقبل فاقنر بعد رحيل زعيمها واضح تماما
ان مستقبل يعني لا يزال غامضا وذلك بسبب
ان لا يمكن ان يتصور المرء وجود بديل يعني
يستجيب لنفس المعايير ويتخذ نفس اساليب
والطرق في نشاطه وممارساته سواء في المجال
العسكري او في مجال البزنس او المجال
الاعمال مثل ما كان ذلك في افريقيا ولكن
الحال الاوضاع التي سوف طبعا تصود روسيا
مستقبلا وحتى من الان تفرض على مثل هذه
الشركات او بدائل المحتمل اليها ان تواصل
ما قام به لن تكون مثل ما كانت ايام
فريجوشن او في عهد لان قامت به هذه
المجموعه
ومكتسباته ونجاحات وكانت مرتبطه باسم رجل
واحد وهو زعيم هذه المجموعه غياب بريغوجين
ستكون له تداعيات في مناطق وجود فاجنر في
العالم هل فعلا تتحسب واشنطن لتغييرات من
هذا القبيل انا لا اتفق مع ذلك لا اعتقد
ان هنالك تغييرا جذريا في اوكرانيا او في
افريقيا على الارض تمت شركه
ولديها ملاك جدد وهو بوتين وقد عوض
القاده من خلال تفجير طائره وسوف ربما يشد
على يد احدهم من القياده الوسطى يكون
مطواعا له وسيقوم بكل ما يامره به ليكون
وكيلا في افريقيا وايضا يستمر في اوكرانيا
بعيدا عن الاعلام لكي لا يكون جديد ولا
يكون سياسيا
[موسيقى]
فانهم بطبيعه الحال ما زالوا يتذكرون تلك
الايام وتلك المحن والتجارب والعمليات
التي عاشوها معا بقياده هذا الرجل الذي
استطاع ان يجمع حوله اناسا في مختلف
التخصصات والمجالات بواسطه ذلك كان قد
تمكن من تحقيق نجاحات وكسب عواطف
الاوساط العريضه الهاشيه مع على مستوى
الشارع الروسي اما كان يفيد موسكو في حاله
فاجنر بمعزل عن شخص هو ما يمكن تسميته
بالكلفه العسكريه المنخفضه يعني هناك
مجموعه مرتزقه تعمل لدى شركه كانت لديها
العديد من الازرعه تستطيع تمويل انشطتها
بنفسها من خلال السطو على مناجم او من
خلال تقاضي اموال من رؤساء دول ومن حكومات
بحجه حما الشخصي لديها ذراع اعلامي يعني
هناك كان كلفه منخفضه
تؤدي مهام قذره وتستطيع موسكو التبرا بها
منها عفوا من جهه وتوظيفها لمفاوضات
لاظهار ان لديها اذرع وقدره على التاثير
في اكثر من ساحه اصبح اي شخص سيرث ما تبقى
من شركه فاجنر اي شخص سيتولى مسؤوليته
يدرك انه بخطر وكل افراد فاغنر بات لديهم
سقف من التوقعات فيما يخص حريتهم
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه يتعين علينا ان نفهم ان فانجر
ليست مجموعه واحده ولكنها مجموعتان هنالك
الحرس القديم في افريقيا والحرس الجديد
وهو في اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا
الحرس الجديد هي تالفوا من المجرمين الذين
اطلق صراحهم من السجون في سنه الماضيه من
قبل
ارسلوا الى جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا
ليقتلوا السؤال الذي يثار هو من هم الحرس
القديم وهم مدربون على نحو الحسن وهم بقوا
خارج اوكرانيا في جل المعارك بقوا في
افريقيا وما فعله هو انه بنى نموذج بزنس
نموذج اعمال لا يحتاج الى ادارته وبوتين
يعرف ذلك اذا هذا هو صاحب الشعر الرمادي
كما يوصف هل هو الاكثر حظوه الان
زعمت باجنر هناك مرشحين اخرين من بينهم
ربما حتى بعض
القاده العسكريين الذين يخدمون في الجيش
انني استبعد احتمال نقلهم من المؤسسه
العسكريه
المحترفه الى هذه المجموعه
بسبب بسيط واحد وهو ان لديه ربما واحد
المرشحين من جهاز الجيش الروسي سوف يكون
علاقه اوطد مع بالك وبالرئيس الروسي وهذا
يعني انه سوف يكون وفيا للرئيس الروسي
بشكل تام بخلاف ما كان ربما مع في حال
تعين شخص جديد يعتبر مقربا من بوتين على
راس فاجنر تعني ان المسافه التي كانت
قائمه انتهت وان وزاره الدفاع او اجهزه
المخابرات او سطوه الكرمل المباشره موجوده
على هذه الشركه وعلى هذه الجماعه
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان هنالك منطقه رماديه بين بين تفضي
الى التوتر لان العالم سيما
توما العسكريه في دول الساحل تنظر الى
موسكو والى فاجنر
وتتساءل ماذا يجري وسوف تقوم بحساباتها
ليصب ذلك في مصلحته
[موسيقى]
من الممكن جدا ان
تشهد وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وبعض حلقات
النقاش على تيليجرام وغيرها
تسريب معلومات ووثائق حول عقود واتفاقات
وحول ثروات التي استفادت منها فاجنر بلا
شك ان تصفيات الحسابات في دوله يعني لا
يوجد فيها معايير من الشفافيه ودوله قانون
بالمعنى الحقيقي للكلمه كل ذلك ممكن وهذا
ينطبق ايضا في المقابل على شركاء هذه
الدوله في افريقيا
اذا ما ردوا استخدام نموذج المرتزقه كيف
يمكن ضبطه وكيف يمكن درء تمردين قادم على
القياده الروسيه الان ان تواجه تحديات
طبعا بعد ما حدث ببريغوجن ولا شك ان
الكريبلين الان ربما سيكون مشغول بايجاد
صيغ مقبوله
لكي تكون بديلا لشركه